[Music]
charity contribution to sports and or
community sponsored by waggle events
Alice cross Center the Alice cross
Center provides a year-long provision of
exercise and activity for the over 50s
and has been offering community-based
activities for 40 years a much-needed
local charity it's well attended and is
essential in overcoming social isolation
actively promoting dementia services in
cooperation with volunteering and health
Alice cross runs a memory cafe each week
these services are provided at minimal
cost as they want to enable the
community to access all activities a
constant influence in Timnath Dawlish
and Newton Abba Alice crosses legacy has
passed on to current and future
generations Kings Care League of Friends
the Kings Care League of Friends set up
originally to support the patients of
the doctor's practice in King Stainton
is now a fully independent and
professional charity that aims to
improve the health well-being and
quality of life of the vulnerable
disadvantaged and frail in our local
community each week Kings Care provide a
range of activities including drop-in
sessions exercise classes and Tai Chi
twice a week they also run guided walks
to help people regain their independence
and confidence there are some truly
remarkable individual success stories
but then King's Care is a truly
remarkable local charity volunteering
and health volunteering in health
support lonely and isolated people in
Timnath and Dawlish they have nearly 200
volunteers who drive people to medical
appointments visit or phone lonely
people at home as the fenders and help
out at memory cafes and fundraising
events also in the last year they've
started a trim team program which anyone
can join Timnath and Dawlish have the
lowest rates of unplanned admissions to
hospital and the best discharge rates
from hospital the charity also works
closely with Sheldon school matching
year 6 pupils with lonely elderly people
to become pen pals
[Music]
you